foreign
considering my recent 17-minute rant
against therapy it will not surprise you
to learn that I do not share modern
society's overriding concern for mental
health as I'll explain in a moment
mental health is important arguably if
we understand the term a certain way a
way very different from how it is
commonly understood but if we accept the
popular narrative about mental health it
will lead us to all sorts of unfortunate
directions it leads us most
unfortunately to a country where some 65
million people are currently taking
psychiatric drugs and in a result not
quite as dire but still pretty bad it
leads us to this article from the
website Essence headline nearly 40 of
black women have quit jobs because they
didn't feel emotionally safe new survey
findings from black women focused from
black women focused mental health app
exhale found that the group often feels
unprotected and discouraged from leaning
into their identity in the workplace now
we don't have the time to dissect every
piece of this so phrases like leaning
into their identity in the workplace
will just have to be left alone for now
at first blush it may seem totally
incoherent I mean how can you lean into
your own identity your identity is just
Who You Are
the rather insufferable lean into
expression normally means that you're
working hard at something that you're
showing great effort and perseverance
how can you work hard at your own
identity
and anyway why is that the kind of work
you'd be doing in the workplace your
employer didn't hire you to sit around
and simply exist as yourself if your
boss asks you what you did all day it'd
be a bad idea to answer well I existed
you know I did a lot of existing uh yeah
I really leaned into my identity in fact
I'm going to bring my home my work home
with me and continue existing even off
the clock that's how committed I am boss
doesn't make much sense until you
understand that by lean into your
identity what they really mean is do and
say whatever you want all the time
and what that really means in context
and in Practical terms is be a lazy
unproductive
that's what anyone who who anyone who
expresses a desire to lean into their
identity in the workplace that's what
they really mean 100 of the time
I know we said we wouldn't spend a lot
of time on this but it turns out that
it's a very relevant Point very relevant
to the main point as we'll see as we
continue quote black women are
increasingly prioritizing their mental
health but it's coming at the cost of
their livelihood exhale a well-being app
specifically for black women and women
of color recently published it's the
state of self-care for black women
report and found that nearly 40 of black
women have left their jobs because they
felt unsafe in their identity quote as
black women we're surrounded with
messages telling us we're strong and
resilient enough to manage stress but
this survey proves that we are
negatively impacted by a lack of
necessary support said Katara McCarty
founder of exhale in a news release
shared with essence
well black women cannot fully heal
without being fully seen we need
culturally appropriate resources and
tools that address the effects of racial
trauma on mental emotional and physical
health
now I have no idea if the numbers here
are correct I suspect they're not
40 percent of black women have left
their jobs because they felt unsafe in
their identity
I would have thought it'd be impossible
to find 40 of adults in any demographic
who would even use the phrase I feel
unsafe in my identity much less leave a
job over it this is the kind of thing
that you might expect a 19 year old
blue-haired Starbucks Barista to scream
as she storms out of her job because a
customer misgendered her that said I'm
leaving I feel so unsafe in my identity
here
I can imagine that
I can't imagine 40 percent of adults in
any group carrying on this way
but perhaps I'm being overly optimistic
I don't know back to the article quote
the report analyzed responses from a
1005 black women in the United States
and unpacks the stressors they
experience every day across various
touch points in their lives particularly
in their professional lives for example
66 percent of respondents say that they
over exert themselves to excel in the
workplace and to take care of personal
responsibilities as Essence previously
reported burnout is prevalent among
black women and can often manifest in
physical ailments quote constantly
striving to be the best of the best
while for foregoing self-care is really
an epidemic among black women uh
Fauntleroy told Essence in uh November
2022 she's a certified acupuncturist and
owner of holistic Wellness practice the
spirit seed and regularly teaches
clients the importance of physiological
interconnectedness in layman's terms she
shows people how mental wounds adversely
affect our overall physical health
well they're really hitting all the
liberal buzzwords aren't they unpack the
stressors lean into their identity touch
points holistic Wellness self-care
I would say that this sounds like it was
written by AI except that the article is
not nearly authentic and human enough to
have been written by AI
now the obvious point is that this is
self-victimization on steroids here we
find another example of this absurd myth
that black women somehow live especially
stressful and difficult lives we're
always being told about this how
difficult it is to be a black can you
imagine being a black woman in today's
society how hard it must be now in
reality
black women are already members of two
privileged classes right out of the gate
and that's before they pad their stats
by adding non-binary or obese or
whatever else to the resume it's clear
that the left has given up their morals
in any common sense that's why there's
no better time to build a daily habit of
prayer meditation building a habit of
prayer can help you cultivate an
attitude of gratitude focusing on what
you're thankful for can increase
positive emotions and improve overall
well-being hallow is the number one
Christian Prayer app in the US it's
helped me maintain a daily prayer
routine can help you do the same
download the app for free at hello.com
Matt Walsh you can set prayer reminders
and track your progress along the way
not sure where to start we'll check out
father Mike schmitz's Bible in a year
podcast available on the hollow app for
brief daily readings and Reflections or
pray alongside Mark Wahlberg Jim
Caviezel even some world-class athletes
with Hollow you can customize a personal
prayer plan that works for you listen
wherever you are with downloadable
offline sessions using hello to connect
with others who share your beliefs and
values can provide a sense of belonging
support and Foster a sense of community
as well ultimately we'll learn how we
can become better individuals in spite
of today's broken World As We strive to
become more like Christ in our daily
lives through prayer fasting and giving
download hello.com Matt walshington
exclusive exclusive three months free
that's three months absolutely free at
hello.com Matt Walsh now sure black
women might have stresses in their lives
they might feel overworked in some cases
burned out so on but so what welcome to
life ladies welcome to reality welcome
to existence as a as a human person in
the world we're all stressed out and
burned out in yada yada I have six kids
to support I have two infants who only
sleep for three hours at a time
okay you want to go toe-to-toe in a
stress match we can do that I know
something about it but I don't sit
around at work or anyone else trying to
unpack it and analyze it and talk about
it and establish physiological
interconnectedness whatever the hell
that means I just live my life and I do
it needs to be done handle my business
until I die that's it that's how life
Works get used to it move on
there's nothing special or unique about
your stresses I guarantee you that your
life is not as hard as you think it is
and even if it is that hard self-pity
won't get you anywhere
so stop moping and get on with it that
brings us finally back to Mental Health
the problem with the whole concept of
mental health as the phrase is commonly
used is understood
is that when someone says that we should
focus on Mental Health
what they usually mean is that we should
focus on feeling good about ourselves
and about our lives when a person
complains about poor mental health they
simply mean most of the time that they
feel bad that they feel stressed out
that they feel irritated sad whatever
the solution then is to prioritize
mental health by doing what makes them
feel good and happy and comfortable
but this is all wrong bad feelings
stressful feelings feelings of burnout
feeling overloaded these are not mental
sicknesses these are not symptoms of
poor mental health these are symptoms of
Simply being a conscious human agent
operating in the world these are
symptoms not of having a sick mind but
Simply Having a mind
so if you talk about do I have stresses
and I have this and I feel uncomfortable
good that means that you're conscious
that means you're a person
the alternative is what to be catatonic
trying to avoid uncomfortable feelings
and experiences that is not prioritizing
your mental health because uncomfortable
feelings and experiences do not
jeopardize your mental health in fact
it's the opposite a mentally healthy
person is a person who experiences
stress and experiences sadness and
discomfort and then continues on
functioning as normal in spite of it in
other words prioritizing your mental
health means going to work
and feeling stressed out and then coming
home and going about your life without
whining about it constantly that's what
a mentally healthy person does
the more you complain the more you
Shield yourself from discomfort by
quitting jobs or taking medicine or
whatever else the more mentally sick you
make yourself now in truth
with all that said
and you know this is the appropriate way
of understanding mental health but I
still don't love the mental health
versus mental sickness language even in
this context
that's because health and sickness are
diagnostic terms they are medical
language
the more that we can take medical
language away from from the mind the
better the more that we can separate
these two and stop thinking of the Mind
as a as as this um entity that that can
be constantly diagnosed with various
sicknesses like the way that you could
be diagnosed with diabetes or or
arthritis or something
the more we can do that the better
you know a woman who leaves her job
because she doesn't feel safe in her
identity
um is not mentally sick exactly this is
a moral defect this is a character flaw
she lacks fortitude she lacks
perseverance she lacks maturity she
lacks strength she's weak she's a coward
she's selfish she's shallow
she's actually just sort of a bad person
okay if you're leaving jobs because I
don't feel unsafe in my identity you're
just like you're a bad person you're not
a good person
you're weak
you're silly you're frivolous
you don't have a medical problem you
have a character problem
this has nothing to do with mental
health one way or another
so even we try to come to a more
coherent understanding of mental health
we still find that it misses the point
it's not a useful Concept in most cases
because as it turns out the best thing
you can do about your mental health
whatever exactly we mean by that is to
stop thinking about it
stop making it the goal and focus the
most mentally healthy people in the
world are the people who've never
thought for one second about their
mental health or done one single thing
for the sake of it okay find me a person
who has never uttered the phrase I'm
prioritizing my mental health that
person is way mentally healthier than
than anyone who who has done the
opposite
that's what mental health looks like
whatever mental health is exactly and
that is why everyone who prioritizes
their Mental Health
is today unfortunately canceled if you'd
like to see what else I have to say you
can access my full show by going to
dailywire.com or by going to the Matt
wall Show Twitter page hope to see you
there Godspeed